well good morning miss good and good
morning campers and top three when it
comes to putting the T in talent a top
three girl apparently I mean you've been
sitting on the secret for a minute what
does it mean to finally get to share
this big moment in your life with the
world so crazy so full circle it's like
it is so bizarre to have a dream come
true
and to be living in it right now well
other is something so monumentally
negative happening in the world and
trying to like marry that to something
that is so monumentally positive in my
in my personal life is so weird like so
strange but it is so amazing I don't
want to fight nobody I'm just here to
win and leave a [ __ ] on red well let's
look into the future that crown is on
your head message to America after you
become America's next drag superstar I
think that it is time to start taking
things less seriously you know make drug
fun again make drag less about the drama
let's not the trolls like there is no
reason for any of that we need to be
lifting each other up and just be
experiencing the entertainment that you
know we're trying to deliver and so I'm
so excited to be able to preach that
whether I get the crown which I will or
I don't you know so it's it's just like
just stop taking things so seriously
okay I'm a man in women's clothing like
just chill I love this platform yes
[Music]
it's been so fun to watch you all season
long and you actually have more
challenge wins than some people who have
gone on to win the competition what does
that mean to you someone said that to be
or day and I just like literally just
realized that's the other day that they
were like you've gotten combined with
mini and maxi challenge wins you have
the most of any girl on the show that
has ever been so that is so strange and
to me internally while this was
happening like in the moment I was like
okay feels good I got a mini challenge
win but I'm not good enough I have to
get another one and the same thing with
the maxi challenge wins so it was just
like to me it was not a matter of
furthering myself in the competition it
was a matter of just like topping myself
every single time so I am really happy
with what I brought I'm so happy that I
have wins just show for it and even the
challenges that I didn't win I am like
there's not a single thing that I would
have changed obviously worked out we're
sitting here talking right now about the
finale I know where we're headed toward
a finale like we've never seen before
what kind of preparation went into this
big day I mean it's if I were on the
road right now like it like I should be
I'm as a nuru girl I would not have any
idea how I'd bring together things that
I've been having to bring them together
and you know obviously it's like it's so
hard to be putting my package for the
finale together right now because stores
aren't open fabric stores aren't open so
we've been having to like hand paint
curtains from Target to like make the
fabric that I need for specific looks
and like everything that I'm doing I'm
so proud to say has been done by hand by
me by my friends and it just puts so
much value to the work that I'm giving
so no matter what happens the finale
I've already won when it sounds like
it's like a next-level challenge it's
already tough enough to go into the
finale have to top everything you did
all season tomorrow oh let's do it while
a pandemic is happen literally it feels
harder than like preparing for the
actual show well this is entertainment
tonight
interview so I have to ask about your
personal life there's a famous the fans
think you and crystal are more than
sisters I know I just I know I know what
the rumors are we've talked about it
we've been socially long distant and I
can't listen that mole that does
something you know I just talked to
right before you and she said she's
excited to see where things go when this
whole quarantine lifts and you guys
couldn't see my um pursue diva I wish we
were quarantined together but we are not
we talk as much as we can and I mean
crystal is one of the most special
people I've ever met
she's incredible what does it mean to
you to get to be in top three with
crystal it's incredible it's I mean like
like I said before like I'm gonna take
the crown but if I did it in some crazy
universe that I didn't take the crown I
would be so honored and happy to have it
go to somebody like crystal and even
Jada like these girls are some of the
best friends that I have ever had and I
think the fact that our drag is also
like so different we are such different
drag queens and it's a top-three like
you've never seen before so if any one
of us took it it would be just
incredible for the history of the show
he's gonna be so exciting to watch the
finale and then watch where you guys go
after this yes absolutely I would love
to tour with them I would love to do
shows with them it's just like I'm
honored to be a part of this with them
was there a quote that stuck out to you
from this season like a line that you'll
be saying forever and ever and ever
I've been saying okay one from the show
and one off the show but the one that's
from the show is Jada saying look over
there I've just been using that for
everything lately and the other thing
I've been saying that didn't happen on
the show but it's a meme with Jen and
Jen she's just something she's sitting
in her apartment and something bangs and
she goes not this not this I say that
for every like I'll say it when I'm on
the phone with my mom and she'll be like
what but you're not the library is open
you got to do a version of this but he
didn't get to do the full mini challenge
of the library challenge so I wonder if
there were any reads you thought of over
the season that you were like I wish I
had been able to pull that out during
the library challenge oh my god I'm the
worst at reading I am so bad at it like
really really bad and I was really glad
we didn't have to do it on the actual
season because the ones that I have
prepared I don't even really like him
out of my memory they were so bad but I
had one for Jan that I came up with
after the season just in case so I can
share with you now yes please okay Jan I
am so proud of you you've been really
pushing your career and doing so much
I've been loving watching your Jan's
jukeboxes um but I'm really tired of my
screen cracking every time I play one
that's good not that bad well I thought
about that for a long time well I'm
excited to see what you do next I don't
know I mean you're giving me like a Mars
Attacks Madonna moment right now so I
after this
[Laughter]
[Music]